non
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir après
jeunes à calmer d'une douzaine d'heures
le feu s'est ranimée au début de l'après
midi dans le var ce fut soudain et cela
s'est produit au moment même où au pc de
draguignan pensait avoir maîtrisé le
sinistre
les principaux points de cette reprise
du brasier se situe au sud est de
brignoles à forcalquier au maillon en
plein vol massif des maures et à celle
des fonds pour aider les sauveteurs et
les sapeurs pompiers de la région on
peut dire qu'il y a vraiment eu une
mobilisation générale
un nouveau contingent de 200 militaires
a été acheminé hier soir vers les
départements du sud-est
à la demande du président de la
république et du ministre de l'intérieur
actuellement il ya 3000 militaires des
armées de terre de mer et de l'air qui
ajoutent leurs efforts leurs efforts à
ceux des pompiers venus d'une trentaine
de départements
par surcroît ceux qui dirigent la lutte
sont persuadés que certains priaient d'
incendies ont été allumés par des
pyromanes par des spécialistes de ce jeu
criminelle gérard holtz
minuit hier coup de téléphone chez les
pompiers du var nous allons mettre le
feu partout est une voix anonyme
sur le terrain on repère des hommes qui
s'enfuient à bord de trois voitures et à
quelques mètres de là des arbustes
s'enflamme dans la nuit à peine croyable
et pourtant depuis quelques jours les
témoignages s'accumulent
par exemple vendredi et samedi plusieurs
pyromanes sont aperçus au coeur du
brasier des morts il y reçoit près du
village de besse les sauveteurs
surprennent un homme en train de mettre
le feu les réussi à s'enfuir enfin la
suite de la découverte d'un foyer près
du camp militaire de canjuers
un incendiaire a été interpellé par
l'armée difficile de croire dans ces
conditions à une génération spontanée
des incendies disent les
sapeurs-pompiers qui déplore déjà 22
blessés dans leurs rangs
après plusieurs heures d'espoir ce matin
des heurts qui ont tout de même permis
aux sauveteurs et aux pilotes des
canadair de prendre un peu de repos
le mistral s'est de nouveau levé en fin
d'après midi trois gros incendies ont
immédiatement repris dont le gigantesque
brasier des morts et quatre nouveaux
foyers attisés par des vents tournants
ont éclaté dans le seul département du
var
la corse n'est pas épargnée non plus
avec de nouveaux foyers près de corte
qui ont obligé les canadair à intervenir
situation sérieuse mais pas dramatique
disent les responsables du pc incendie
qui veulent rester optimistes sur
l'évolution de la météo
de nouveaux renforts trois mille hommes
pompiers ou soldats venus de tous les
coins de france sont arrivés aujourd'hui
sur le terrain les sapeurs-pompiers
forme l'un des corps va la nation les
plus dévoués à la collectivité nationale
ce qu'ils font nécessite de l'habileté
de l'intelligence et le mépris du danger
ils doivent aussi savoir résister à des
fatigues qui vont parfois aux limites du
supportable pour l'organisme humain
comme ces trois dernières nuits qui pour
eux ont été des nuits blanches
notre envoyé spécial gérard in et vous
présente la journée d'un sapeur-pompier
reportage tourné au milieu même de ces
incendies dans le bas mais pour ceux des
merveilles du cours parce que ça
la swde
vous êtes volontaire là je suis
professeur professionnels
qu'est ce que tu t'es nul à la chaleur
ou la fumée la fumée
pour quelques jours après avoir mal à la
tête
ça fait deux jours que vous en cuira
laifaoui depuis 1
vous n'êtes pas du tout reposer de la
nuit comme dans les moments critiques
le rôle des tic sont effondrés la
chaleur commence à se faire sentir et ça
ça rate is tous les cas tous les foyers
qui était que la péter parce que l'été
s'est passé votre ennemi c'est à la
chaleur et le vent et le valois de la
vergne est plutôt vague
parce que le zinc gourmet ait pas mis en
relation des potes comme ça on
arriverait j'avais du bar on arriverait
il aurait déjà ce qu'elles sont
aussi pas le 5e risque comme qui
le larguer là il argue le plus comme ils
ont la cote ils sont obligés de remonter
de suite
hier sur le feu et plusieurs pompiers
blessés ça vous y pensez ça idiot de
brignoles vous souhaitiez pompiers
volontaires avant d'être pompier
professionnel donc oui mais qui a tiré
par le pot oui bah c'est à dire que
telle dans les loges sont les tribus
anton d'aller voir partir les pompiers
puis j'ai passé c'est un truc de gosse
puis ça ça ça se garde hier le président
de la république venu du fort de
brégançon jusqu'au massif du feu avait
rendu hommage aux efforts des sauveteurs
ce matin après avoir écouté la messe à
la londe en bordure du massif des maures
le chef de l'état et son épouse se sont
rendus à la caserne des sapeurs-pompiers
de la localité où ils se sont longuement
entretenus avec p soldats du feu le
ministre du travail monsieur boulin a
depuis quelques jours sur son bureau un
rapport sur l'aménagement du temps ce
texte étudie la répartition possible
pour les dix années à venir entre le
temps de travail et le temps des loisirs
l'un de ses chapitres intéresse au
premier chef des consommateurs les
grandes surfaces qui ouvrent le dimanche
pourrait être désormais plus nombreuses
partout en france principalement pour
les achats que l'on appelle de caractère
familial comme les meubles
il semble qu'il y ait un consensus pour
ébranler un peu plus encore la notion si
longtemps sacro-sainte du repos
hebdomadaire le dimanche large accord
visage sauf de la part de certains
petits commerçants des syndicats soit
des employés de ces grandes surfaces
pour en savoir davantage vous invite à
suivre le reportage de gérard belmas
héritage chrétien devenu acquis social
le repos obligatoire du dimanche se
fendit chaque week-end jusqu'à la grande
bretagne qui songe à briser légalement
sa tradition des commerçants silencieux
du dimanche chez nous au mépris de la
loi et à défaut d'obtenir des
dérogations parfois dignes de courteline
et curieusement accordé selon les
départements
certaines grandes surfaces préfère
supporter de très lourdes amendes plutôt
que de faire coïncider repos
hebdomadaire et fermeture dominicale le
dimanche représentant le tiers du
chiffre hebdomadaire
nous avons des amendes parce que nous
ouvrons dimanche le dimanche est un
besoin pour le public pour faire ses
approvisionnements et leur code du
travail interdit le travail de dimanche
bien qu'il y ait une dérogation
l'article 221 6 qui annick que si c'est
préjudiciable au public ou préjudiciable
à la société le magasin peut avoir une
dérogation pour ouvrir l'oeil
malheureusement nous n'avons jamais
privé des chiffres d'affaires du
dimanche
nous sommes obligés de fermer notre
société nous vendons un marges basses
nous vendons les biens d'équipement en
grande série et par conséquence si on
nous ferme le dimanche nous ferment la
société pour les petits commerçants il
ya concurrence déloyale actuellement les
dérogations d'ouverture contourne la loi
royer limitant l'implantation des grands
pour les organismes de consommateurs
l'assouplissement des dérogations doit
être équitable autrement c'est
avantageux pour les employés et pratique
pour le public
certes contraint d'acheter le dimanche
solution un aménagement des horaires et
des transports en semaine quant aux
acheteurs du dimanche c'est un oui franc
et massif
on a quand même un peu plus le temps que
le quinze jours de semaine
sur du travail on attend de la vie
rurale dimanche on vient d'abord c'est
agréable
c'est pas loin de chez nous et puis je
vous dis on a le temps on travaille les
enfants du sabot bas niveaux sont bien
en promenade et on décide de nos achats
tranquillement nous les obligeons pas
amené en neuvième manche quand nous en
30 à 35% du chiffre c'est que c'est un
besoin pour la clientèle de trouver les
magasins ouverts le dimanche
oui mais cela on peut répondre par
exemple que ça prouve que les gens n'ont
pas le temps de vivre en semaine c'est
possible nous sommes dans un secteur où
nous pourrons considérer que ce sont des
dortoirs bon les gens travaillent à
paris revient le soir je vous ai parlé
tout à l'heure des captures qui marche
absolument pas chez nous donc c'est bien
le dimanche que le public est disponible
côté emploi c'est positif y compris en
amont et en aval
mais pour le syndicat pouvoir prendre
son congé ensemble reste capital dans la
qualité de la vie pour les acheteurs
comme pour les travailleurs d'ailleurs
dans ses hypermarchés parmi le personnel
qu'il peut pratiquement pas refuser de
travailler le week end malgré
l'intéressement de tous au vent demain
dimanche
l'ouverture ne fait pas l'unanimité dans
les familles on s'adapte et surtout on y
trouve un intérêt
on vend bien le dimanche tous les
services sont touchés
donc s'ils voulaient plus il ya de
chiffre d'affaires plus il ya de
personnes employées un donc tout le
monde vous dit tout le monde est
concerné par l'ouverture le dimanche à
l'unanimité tout le monde est d'accord
tout le monde en profite tout le monde
en profite bien sûr nous à la vente si
vous voulez on est plus haut pourcentage
on a tout intérêt à travailler le
dimanche
pas moi par exemple j'ai deux enfants je
suis marié et j'ai deux jours de congé
en semaine je le prends mercredi je peux
avoir mes enfants justement qui fait que
bon bah ils sont avec moi et j'en
profite mieux
finalement ma femme travaille
du lundi au vendredi soir donc
pratiquement je ne la voit jamais
pratiquement de la semaine j'arrive très
tard conforama orgeval
il y à 40% du personnel qui est divorcée
un significatif
à notre avis il ya aucun avantage est ce
que les magasins soient ouverts le
dimanche bon on nie pas qui est que les
travailleurs et des difficultés pour
faire leurs courses
bon mais ça c'est dû essentiellement à
la durée du travail autant de transport
et aussi aux charges que
quand les familles c'est à dire
s'occuper des enfants les tâches
ménagères bon et que pour nous la
solution c'est pas d'ouvrir les magasins
le dimanche
c'est pas de prolonger les nocturnes
mais c'est la reddition travail remède
cfdt
la semaine de 35 heures permettant aussi
au public d'acheter en semaine les
besoins restants les mêmes de toutes les
faces et puis si la liberté
d'entreprendre doit demeurer toute la
semaine
il faut une politique de loisirs rendant
au dimanche sa vocation car la machine à
consommer agréable voire euphorique nous
incite sans trêve ni repos et avec cette
escalade à l'ouverture on parlera
bientôt deux dimanches ouvrables de
trois pages de travers commence par une
catastrophe s'est produite dans l'ain en
inde un barrage de terre s'est rompue
l'année dernière à 500 km environ au
nord de bombay dans l'état de gujarat
près de 1000 personnes ne disaient des
pêches ont été englouties par les eaux
je n'en sais pas plus au cours de la
récente maladie du premier ministre
israélien begin l'opposition avait
vivement souhaité son départ des
affaires ce matin en présidente à
nouveau le conseil des ministres il a
déclaré qu'il remplirait son mandat
jusqu'au terme normal c'est à dire
jusqu'aux élections générales en 1980 à
damas le conseil national palestinien a
chargé me sert à rabat de poursuivre ses
contacts avec les pays occidentaux
vous vous souvenez entre autres des bons
entretiens qu'il avait eus le mois
dernier à vienne avec le chancelier
autrichien secret ce qui est l'ex
chancelier allemand monsieur willy brad
à ces travaux de damas dont je vous
parlais on a noté pour la première fois
depuis cinq ans la participation de
monsieur habache leader du front
populaire de libération de la palestine
l'une des tendances les plus dures du
front du refus cela signifie sans doute
un assouplissement
car jusqu'à présent les membres du front
du refus s'opposait à la moindre
négociation sur israël au sahara
occidental l'armée marocaine occupe
désormais la totalité de la province de
thierry salles car bien et le drapeau
chérifien flotte depuis hier soir sur
battre la céleste villa cisneros une
localité qui évoque pour nous français
l'épopée de mermoz qui en utilisent a
jadis l'aéroport quand il crée la
fameuse ligne de l'atlantique sud
drôle de cérémonie pour une drôle de
guerre
mais la levée de ces couleurs mérite
tout de même une explication les cartes
étant sérieusement embrouilles
il ya quatre jours la mauritanie signé
un accord avec le front polisario pour
se retirer du guêpier ça rien et c'est à
la suite de cet accord que les troupes
mauritaniennes décidé d'abandonner d'arc
l'a aussitôt les traînards auquel sont
arrivés pour les remplacer parce que la
population nous réclamer 10 les
marocains en fait pour ne pas laisser le
champ libre au front polisario de toute
évidence la présence des forces de rabat
dans cette région est la concrétisation
du marché conclu il ya deux autres
marocains mauritaniens
il se confirme en effet que nouakchott a
décidé de laisser les mains libres aux
marocains dans le sahara les marocains
en contrepartie se seraient engagés à ne
pas favoriser les oppositions régime
britannique
l'inconnue c'est l'attitude future de
l'algérie qui soutient le front
polisario et qui a dénoncé aujourd'hui
l'agression marocaine contre le peuple
sahraoui
on vient de rendre publique à alger un
récent message de monsieur giscard
d'estaing ou le président de la
république se déclarer convaincu que
l'algérie et la france étaient en mesure
de dissiper des malentendus apparues
entre les deux pays
s'adressant au nouveau président de
l'algérie monsieur chadli bendjedid
monsieur giscard d'estaing a écrit que
les liens qui unissent les deux pays
fondées ce rattachement commun au
respect de leur choix et des valeurs qui
leur sont propres
les appels au dialogue et à la
concertation pour dissiper les
malentendus et entretenir une
coopération amicale et qu'on en iran
la nouvelle loi sur la presse a été
commenté cet après midi par le ministre
de l'orientation nationale
elle impose l'interdiction de publier
quelques organes de presse que ce soit à
ceux qui ont étaient de proches associés
de l'ancien régime et notamment ceux qui
ont servi de chat entre 1963 début de
l'exil de la plaque khomeiny et février
79 date du retour de celui-ci
by journaux au biquotidien et deux
hebdomadaires sont ainsi interdits
le ministre de l'orientation a confirmé
la saisie de l'imprimerie du journal
ayant des gannes au profit de
l'organisation nationale des indigents
motif cette imprimerie a été créée ville
ministre avec des fonds israéliens on en
a même parlé avant tiers des fonds du
contre espionnage américain aussi à et
et de ceux de la sape
le ministre a ajouté les collaborateurs
de chômage ont été arrêtées et l'examen
de leurs risques et se poursuivent entre
8 à 10 tomic
de plus nous condamnons at il dit les
manifestations publiques de ceux qui se
prétendent des défenseurs de la liberté
de la presse et prennent le parti de
journaux comme liam dégâts selon le
larousse en trois volumes ville de
bavière vieille cité marchande
soixante deux mille habitants industries
mécaniques et textiles siège du théâtre
des festivals construit à la fin du
siècle dernier pour la représentation
des oeuvres de wagner
tout ceci est vrai sur la bourse en fait
ben wright est devenu l'un des plus
hauts lieux de la musique dans le monde
c'est la capitale du véritable culte que
d'innombrables mélomanes vous à richard
wagner dans un théâtre de briques roses
voulu et conçu par lui-même le
festivalier chaque année un très grand
et un très exaltant moment et cette
année les représentations ils ont
particulièrement réussi
un reportage de michel becker
byron une petite bulle en allemagne
paisible un peu ennuyeuse
sauf lorsque une fois par an arrive la
marée de wagner
c'est alors que les wagnériens
envahissent hôtel parking et restaurants
leur but
le fait subir aux sept mecs ou trois
semaines durant et le vivront l'oeuvre
de wagner joués par les plus grands
interprètes du monde
c'est là que pleins d'espoir du
tenteront d'obtenir une dernière carte
pour le grand voyage vers le ring
tana aussi crible
c'est là que dans l'enceinte du saint
des saints les fanatiques de wagner ceux
qui viennent ici depuis quinze ou vingt
ans revoir les mêmes opéra signeront
mutuellement avec la même splendeur
c'est là que tout bijou étoiles est
déployée il s'indigne rond de la moindre
infidélité des metteurs en scène ou chef
d'orchestre par rapport à l'oeuvre du
maître
surtout lorsque les français patrice
chéreau et pierre boulez seront à
l'oeuvre
ce public de byron mérite cependant
mieux que l'image que l'on conserve de
lui ils évoluent ils changent et se
renouvelle
c'est du moins l'avis des observateurs
les plus attentifs je crois que le
public c'est dans sa majorité ce qui
vient voir puisque on a parlé tellement
de cette mise en scène
chéreau et de la table aux açores du
bruel c'est ce qui vient voir il ya
peut-être de mauvaises raisons il ya sur
le snobisme entre sûrement je baille
retraite à festival de prestige est
inentamé depuis 100 ans si je pense que
si le public vient à bayreuth en sachant
ce qu'il va voir et s'il vient surtout
ouvert
je ne dis pas conquis d'avancé
inconditionnels qui est également très
désagréable filière ouvert de coeur de
sensibilité et d'esprit au spectacle
il va voir avec ce ring je crois qu'il
devient plus intelligent
de fait la mise en scène de patrice
chéreau et la mise en musique de pierre
boulez ont provoqué un véritable
scandale en 76 depuis les choses ont
évolué et cette année on peut pour les
deux français parlé d'un triomphe ce qui
n'impressionne pas tellement des
artistes qui s'intéresse plus à wagner
co wagnérien
c'est ce qu'on appelle en général
wagnérien c'est quelqu'un en effet qui -
m'intéresse assez peu je dirais que ça
creuse s'attacher à une oeuvre
exclusivement fut-elle d'un conte
visiteurs prêts génial je ne vois pas du
tout quoi que ce soit d'intéressant là
dedans
cette espèce d'uniformité du goût des
espèces de faune légalisation totale du
goût rassurez vous musical au goût
théâtrale sur une seule oeuvre me paraît
très mesquin comme point de vue c'est
pour ça que ce genre de wagnérien je
veux dire me laisse absolument
indifférent
ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup plus c'est
de voir tout de même qu'il ya des
personnes qui considèrent en effet le
théâtre de wagner comme un des moments
non seulement les plus importants du
théâtre en tant que tel mais on n'est
plus un port un événement les plus
importants de la culture européenne par
rapport à d'autres moments de cette
culture européenne cela m'intéresse bien
davantage et je crois que cela dure est
manifeste certainement un esprit
beaucoup plus ouvert que les gens qui se
restreignent si vous voulez à une oeuvre
précise
en dépit de cette attitude bayrou il
restera encore longtemps le temple d'une
religion pour initier une religion qui a
ses manies ses vieilleries ses
petitesses ses grandeurs et surtout ce
temple de briques rouges voulu et conçu
par wagner lui même
cela dit et il fallait le dire ben
wright n'est pas le seul lieu au monde
on célèbre bague mère comme il convient
hier soir par exemple plus de 13000
personnes en vue d'un triomphe au
théâtre antique d'orange je peux dire
c'est se disputait à deauville prix du
journal du dimanche 19 partants sur 2000
mètres et à deauville vous le savez la
ligne droite est si courte que si vous
étiez cheval et si vous voulez gagner il
faudrait que vous teniez parmi les tous
premiers bien avant le dernier tournant
sous peine de ne pas or le temps de
revenir tu es un jockey dans la casaque
et violette au mans cercles et jaune et
violet celui qui va gagner
pour le moment le très très rapide les
chevaux sont groupés casaque bleue toque
grenat une première attaque deux grands
moghols mais son poids est sévère et il
va entrer dans le rang un petit peu
d'air à droite un cheval gris royal
pinacle ils sont 5 6 est sur la même
ligne à 200 mètres du poteau à gauche
vers la corde kazakh vert et rouge
c'est malak al hawa qui va faire une
pointe formidable mais il se ressent
encore peut-être son accident du début
de l'année et il sera sûrement place et
voici venir la casaque de l'été jaune
sense prime briques père il n'a pas pu
passer juste ici mais la voie est libre
il passe il a gagné monté par abonné est
entraînée par koné il a pris le meilleur
sur roya pinnacle et malak est la moins
au journal d'hier soir nous donnions
tiercé quoique sans ordre 17 10 et 12 et
les rapports s'inscrivent sur vos écrans
6949 syncope 12 132 pour 5 francs
quant aux prix jacques le marois course
ultra classique elle a été remportée par
irish révéré madame hadès le poulain
confirme ainsi qu'il est le meilleur
d'europe et peut être du monde sur les
distances moyennes
c'est à dire en hippisme jusqu'à 1800 ou
2000 mètres il n'y a pas que les chevaux
alerte et en bonne santé
il ya ceux qui souffrent d'un certain
nombre de maux dont nous pouvons nous
aussi des êtres humains s'offrir à
l'occasion par exemple les rhumatismes
ou les séquelles de fracture pour
l'homme la place aux thérapies c'est à
dire la thérapeutique par l'eau de mer
est une manière agréable et forte
efficace le soigner les douleurs
le cheval est bien aussi bref pirette
bresse vous met dans le bain
après avoir battu des records de vitesse
à longchamp ou ailleurs où après avoir
effectué une saison de course éprouvante
sur les obstacles comme tous les
athlètes les pur sang ont aussi besoin
de soigner leur genre et leur moral on
ne peut pas dire que pour eux le meeting
de deauville soit vraiment de tout repos
mais le simple fait de changer d'air et
d'habitude puisqu'il ne travaille plus
sur les mêmes pistes et que pendant un
mois ils nous habite une écurie nouvelle
les cheveux retrouvent un second souffle
certains entraîneurs profite du bord de
mer pour utiliser les bienfaits de la
thalassothérapie qui selon eux agit
comme une cure miracle sur les chevaux
qui ont des tendons fragile et les
jambes fatiguées
et ce alors refroidi énormément les
jambes et surtout les tendons qui sont
fatigués après les séances
d'entraînement ça tonifie les muscles ça
tonifie les articulations débouler des
genoux et mais surtout sen bienfait
énorme sur les tendons ça les refroidit
tout de suite après un peu de chaleur du
un effort au bout d'une demi heure de
bain de mer
les chevaux sont absolument les jambes
classés et sur la chance de pouvoir
commencer comme ça des séances tous les
jours pendant quinzaine de jours ou
trois semaines pendant le meeting de
deauville les chevaux entre à paris et
cela sur les améliorer normes et man
quels sont les avantages de l'eau de mer
dans ces traitements l'eau de mer est
très complète et laurent et le renferme
beaucoup d'éléments minéraux à savoir
llyod le sodium et le potassium et elle
est très équilibré c'est d'ailleurs un
milieu vivant en parfait équilibre
vous pensez qu'un mois de traitement
pour les chevaux qu'ils initient à
deauville est suffisant pour les
remettre sur jambes
oui justement je pense que l' avantage
de la thalassothérapie et d'accélérer
les procédés empirique des bains de mer
et grâce à ces techniques j'ai pu
récupérer des cheveux aux condamnés par
la médecine classique en des temps que
je pus avait qualifié de record des
temps de trois semaines à un mois
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que je pense
que la thalassothérapie peut être très
efficace pour les assurances qui qui
couvre maintenant les le risque d'
indemnité de non usage et on peut
raccourcir considérablement le délai de
validité d'un cheval handicapés
lorsqu'il a les tendons fatigué ou un
accident au tendon ou des plaies qui
sont très difficiles à guérir par
exemple cette partie postérieure du
tendon qui d'ailleurs chez ce cheval la
part est déjà légèrement déformé donc il
serait à la limite du placage là c'est
ça il faut donc mettre des traitements
pour essayer de diminuer c'était ce
phénomène inflammatoire et pour
renforcer le tendon et l'autre tendon et
bien droit donc c'est normal le temps de
l'autre tendon et bien droit
mais comme ils risquent de se servir
peut-être davantage de l'autre membre et
qu'il ya peut être une fragilité chez ce
cheval là le propriétaire a enduit
également d'argile les deux membres de
son cheval et vous avez pu constater
vraiment des résultats après ce genre de
séance
ben moi ça fait 25 ans je le fais je les
fais d'abord avec mon père maintenant je
le fais avec mes chevaux et c'est pour
ça que je continue parce que je suis
absolument persuadé du succès il faut
quand ils sont en course et bien je
crois davantage un obstacle campe là
d'ailleurs font énormément d'efforts sur
l'argent non oui mon frère il en faut
bien sûr sans faute et un peu plus sur
l'obstacle parce qu'il ya les bons les
réceptions qui sont très dures mais
enfin la vitesse du plat mais qui vaut
même ses forces sur les sur les tendons
donc
je suis étonné qu'il n'y ait pas plus de
chevaux sur la plage pour faire ce genre
de traitement qui ne coûte rien
automobile le grand prix d'autriche a
été gagnée par l'australien alan jones
pilote lancé williams solide ya le
français jacques la fidh et troisième
sur cette lignée mais rené arnoux sur
renault turbo a établi le record du tour
à plus de 223 kilomètres à l'heure au
classement du championnat du monde des
comics père joe directeur afrique du sud
est toujours en tête sur ferrari
après ce détour par l'automobile nous
revenons à l'eau de mer il s'agit
toujours de la mer et non plus de
chevaux du tour de france à la voile
pour
oh
14e étape du tour de france à la voile
le cap d'agde la grande motte sur ces
rivages du languedoc roussillon les
marinas se suivent et se ressemblent la
surprise par contre bien du vent il est
présent là où les concurrents ne
l'attendait pas sur cette côte
méditerranéenne à vent assez violent et
pour conséquence un départ mouvementé au
cap d'agde le first 30 de rennes
l'apprendre à ses dépens en brisant une
de ces barres de flèche dans une
collision avec un autre bateau la barre
de flèche c'est cette pièce en métal
fixé dans le maquis permet d'écarter les
haubans cet incident coûtera à rennes
une heure de retard
un autre voilier endommagé lors de cette
14e étape
nantes un choc assez rude qui se
traduira lui par un trou dans la coque
pour les nantais fait que cela que y ait
toujours des incidents quand les départs
sont assez chaud hein
inévitablement les bateaux comme ça et
c'est de 2,2 fois quelques secondes pour
prendre des risques ou même temps en
temps ne voit pas malgré tout
malgré tout les veilleurs qui peut y
avoir à bord il faut très bien ne pas
voir parce qu'évidemment avec le phoque
et toutes les voiles qu'on a souvent on
voit pas nécessairement les bateaux qui
sont sous le bateau un sous le vent du
gâteau et c'est assez fréquent sur leur
planète
fin mai des chocs aussi violence c'est
comme assez rare l'avantagent des
bateaux construits en plastique n'est
pas négligeable dans ce genre d'incident
il suffit de quelques minutes pour
réparer
à l'arrivée à la grande motte c'est le
régional de la course le voilier la
grande motte qui remportera l'étape le
vainqueur en temps réel flandre se
trouvant déclassé pour avoir oublié une
bouée de parcours le classement général
reste à changer brest toujours en tête
par contre marseille second effectué une
belle remontée en reprenant 30 minutes
sur le leader hier sur un tempo et comme
un stade de aujourd'hui vous avez pu
assister aux championnats du monde de
vol libre à saint-hilaire du touvet
isère
nous allons avec le sourire nous
transporter aujourd'hui en grande
bretagne pour un spectacle sensiblement
semble parler de l'individualisme
britannique t comme chacun sait un lieu
commun
personne ne s'étonnera donc à l'époque
de concorde
quelques insulaire obstinée persistant à
rechercher une solution personnelle au
problème des transports
de ce fait god save the queen leur
tenant lieu de ceinture de sauvetage
ils demeurent les rois dans un domaine
où personne ne cherche à leur ravir
napalm
c'est à dire sinon l'aviation du moins
la marine ainsi soit il les amateurs de
cinéma fêteront demain années 80 en
matériaux grand monsieur le président ce
coq actuellement dans sa maison des
montagnes de santa cruz en californie
il s'offre un festival de petits plats
mijotés par sa femme et il prépare le
scénario de son 54e film sujet mystère
comme toujours chez hitchcock
quant à la météo et bien le temps sera
toujours beau et chaud dans le midi
demain avec ralentissement du vent près
de la méditerranée ailleurs après une
matinée souvent brumeuse
le ciel sera nuageux avec de belles
éclaircies
il se couvrira cependant dans l'extrême
ouest et près de la manche et de petites
pluies sont probables au cours de la
journée des températures seront voisines
de ce qu'on appelle lé normal c'est à
dire vers 23 heures c'est ma famille à
dino qui vous présentera le dernier
journal demain antenne 2010 présenté par
daniel bilalian
daniel bilalian que vous retrouverez
demain soir ici même car il vous
présentera l'édition de 21 bonsoir
à